[Music]
in [ __ ] up news aw damn that's my
favorite type of news submitted by I'm
sorry geo oh no the dead animals in this
one a veterinary student was arrested
for selling rescue horses illegally well
maybe they had a good reason to because
to eat blue horse hooves oh I thought it
was because they were raised horses and
then they she they wanted someone to
take care of them so that people could
[ __ ] Oh Oh laughing that guy from
Portland I was getting far too rarely do
people want to [ __ ] horses most people
want horses to [ __ ] them
yeah yeah that's what I meant but
they're there penises are like the size
of two arms put why here we have to say
I'm like on the edge of my seat here
student her name is a felon she's 24
years old like a [ __ ] I hate you was
arrested because she was smuggling
horses out of the vet she was put a
sheen horse is out of the country to
take them to Mexican slaughterhouses
after she promised to rescue feet like
so there wasn't a [ __ ] is wrong with
this [ __ ] right up straight join a
Mossad muscle making her main hustle
horses yeah she found this woman on
Facebook and so this woman posted on
Facebook and ad like she's trying to
find a home for her horse cuz she could
no longer take beautiful homes dude
stomachs crazy I know another one she
had a or this woman she was moving like
different states what a shady [ __ ] and
so she needed somewhere to house her two
horses yes she's like oh two getting two
birds don't ya
yeah so then she ended up
lying to her as well and saying like oh
yeah I'll hold on to them don't worry
they'll be well taken care we have an
equestrian center by the time you are
settled in some portion you'll have your
horses back right but they don't ever
again heard from the horses wait so she
was supposed to just like babysit yeah
baby semester was a black it was a horse
and you think she's the real name or
she's like an I got a moniker a mule
what do you think like what do you think
the steps to becoming a horse trafficker
was there's no way this is like your
first weird decision do you think she
got approached or she approached them
cuz I kind of feel like it was like hey
you know where you're a vet right you
know where I could get some horses it's
like you get one of those like direct
messages rights and it's like would you
like to buy kratom we sell anabolic
steroids can we help you out of thing on
the card pass no well I don't know about
all of them because they authorities
believe that she might be linked to more
than like 50 horses
this [ __ ] is bald dude she doesn't
think they would catch her I don't know
she also owned a trucking company horses
are [ __ ] huge
I know so she's a student in Alabama but
she was also cautious arrested on a
similar charge last year in North
Carolina and so she's indicted on 13
counts of horse lottery no so it's um
obtaining and false pretences ltd party
under false pretenses good job shake
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] horse thief she
looks like a horse blow room whoa
anybody see Sally horse thief I'm so she
looks awesome when she goes about what
if my last name dude I hate her I like
this she's crying do you think she just
got too deep yeah just a little bit I
just she was rolling in that [ __ ]
money that's what was too deep found she
was like horse I don't know how to be a
good amount of money Mexicans like to
eat horse I didn't even know
I didn't know we had horse slaughtered
please mexico mean you got your horses
somewhere no I didn't know that cuz I
mean I know in Japan they eat [ __ ]
ya know everywhere basically delicious
we stayed horse here we did yeah before
we made them we made them our friends
well we don't typically use animals that
we also use for work yeah that's for
work you could you know yeah they're all
originally they're like pest control
right on the farm do you have to catch
the rats and also I can't believe cat me
but tastes good yeah I don't know they
taste anyway the [ __ ] mouth smells
right what's a straight books NASA got
three balls like two bullet holes push
together coated in salmon juice yes have
you smelled cat [ __ ]
no it's disgusting dude it's like baby
diarrhea at nîmes been smells just like
it tastes delicious
so yes you know how I said she was a
student a student of death at that
school said that she made bail and that
she returns school and that she's on
track to graduate school take her back I
mean like where man you know don't judge
real weird week man PCP in her I was
thinking that she got horses that people
were just going to like like those
racehorses just they're gonna die anyway
yeah anyways and then she decided to
sell it's not a sanctuary yeah I mean
I'm not saying either or was right but I
thought it was that I know somebody's
[ __ ] pet but she said y'all watch
little [ __ ] speedster for you kill
her we open like a like a dog sitting
agency and then you just slaughter them
adeno yeah we were sending it to the
Yulin Dog Festival eat dogs and [ __ ]
it's weird stuff man but I thought like
harming animals why cos she didn't
really harmed she wasn't doing herself
yeah but she's sending them to their
death though but what about she's
thieving thief for obtaining property
under false pretenses yeah but she
didn't show up linking a bandana I like
the Old West and untie your horse and
ride off with it so like that
Jori with the lady with the Facebook
thing right so she said that when she
contacted her she was like oh you know
you could have your horse willy live
with me for the rest of his days and
he'll be fine
so she was like okay I'll go to you so
he can meet you to know me whatever she
said that she showed up with the horse
trailer attached to her truck and she
insisted on her taking I need this horse
you don't understand it she was like
lady doesn't know how close she got to
get in stance what she likes spider
senses was weird she ended up giving in
and she let her take Willy oh come on
Lady the horse started screaming she
stopped responding to her calls and
texts after she got Willy and she's
really so annoying and making all that
noise turn cats back onto him she
offered her money an offer right so to
buy Willie back from her but then she
ignored Tokaido I can't cuz Willie's
yeah Willie's in some tacos now are
breaking
that's messed up yeah a horse is nice
and all but no bite or kick the [ __ ] out
of you so no it's not act like they're
all cool they're super cool you got a
beef about them probably for a while
some of them are kind of egotistical the
way they trot around you just all
prancing like you get out of here buddy
came to that I never got in a fight
raise your tail there's a lot of weird
things like dump a [ __ ] out of you just
falls on the ground a lot of these
animals like we see on TV a lot so like
I like I was just talking about a camel
I saw in person even a [ __ ] horse is
[ __ ] huge they're huge a mess I want
to see people [ __ ] around with them
like you could die this one could kick
your [ __ ] all the way to it if I don't
get people that stand behind the horse
and like slashed all loosey-goosey like
you're safe back there like I'd knock
your [ __ ] teeth then go on youtube and
watch a horse chiropractor that she saw
everybody did I watch that [ __ ] for ASMR
purposes is important thing works on you
not so much anymore only only
chiropractic bathrooms
more because when I first started I got
kind of used to it now now it's like
whatever so before it helped used to
help me relax to go to sleep a horse you
know so I don't want unique specific
ASMR stuff but I'll watch there's a
channel I'll watch especially once I get
real hot like a hand tool rescue and
this guy takes like old hand tools from
like 20s that's don't like takes him all
the way apart and it's all done it like
two times speed so it's all like it's
kind of quiet it's got to be the same
thing as ASMR that's a--that's like a
form of it too right it's just not like
some fingernails on a microphone exactly
so I used to watch something similar to
that one they will restore old swords
and knives
he's [ __ ] he's like a horse
chiropractor and he's [ __ ] releasing
the horses back just like it's hip and
Irene studies a horse awake yeah and
standing and it seems like the horse
[ __ ] likes it he's like yeah like
horses but if it works per se but it's a
wild [ __ ] just like how do you get to
that point how did you decide in
connection with this certain animal no
what I'm saying is are you a
chiropractor right and then some guy
comes along and he's like man my horse
is acting kind of funky like walk around
a little weird hit me like you think you
could work on him doc and he's like the
heart surgeon yeah okay that's what I
thought we were going yeah he's gonna be
a real doctor though she's a horse heart
surgeon so random like how do you become
a horse chiropractor I don't know that's
what I'm saying
because even like regular chiropractic
my chiropractic is already under
suspicion as being like you know not
like some real [ __ ] then how do you go
and be like okay well I know that's not
true but horse chiropractor because all
chiropractor thing is weird yeah or the
babies oh yeah yeah they're little
infinitely the there's a lot of really
cool stuff with chiropractic stuff for
sure oh my god readjusting stuff and
stuff like that but there's also a tone
of [ __ ] yeah yeah I think the people
that started the whole
our practice movement is batshit crazy
mm-hmm
and it's like we can do this and you'll
you can fix anything with chiropractic
work like Oh your eyesight your mother
hey there's a period that like they
thought chiropractors could just need it
to align your spine we would sew sew
Bart's mom goes to his chiropractor that
you've been going to since you're a
little kid right
my mom's addicted to hoaxes oh come on
so there's this guy there's this guy
that she likes magic been there she's
been there my mom goes there and the
first thing he always does so come in
and tell me your ankle hurts like you
twisted ah okay okay come come you sit
down sit down please thank you thank you
come here sit down okay see ya okay look
over here see the angle goes that way
okay turn this way and go for that oh
that's why the angle here is different
okay okay I've got in with [ __ ]
sprained arms sprained shoulder ankle
doesn't matter what it's worth the neck
and you're done okay sign doesn't work
no it doesn't why do you ever do a
secondary goal
so I went there back in the high school
to get like during wrestling practice
that when I like got injuries and then I
would just roll with my mom because she
just wanted someone to go with all right
and my mom's going in there for stomach
aches for all these random things and
it's always the same [ __ ] [ __ ] on my
mom why do you keep coming here cause
trust me it works
I wonder she goes for diarrhea all the
anger you go there's like grass for
[ __ ] labias watch this okay
make eye contact with why he does okay
[Music]